this video is sponsored by onedrive
seriously your brain is going to love
this place in running a science
education channel i like to think i'm
pretty good at explaining scientific
principles and covering interesting
topics but in order to be a good teacher
you have to be a curious student and
learning has always been a hobby of mine
for someone with a wide interest in
topics and an appetite for knowledge i
found one dream to be an excellent
resource to learn new things their
courses are taught by instructors who
are real professionals in their own
field offering both short and long form
videos their curated collection covers
every kind of topic no really they cover
everything from playing piano to
astrophysics to brewing beer
screenwriting documentaries on communism
and learning cryptocurrency one dream
has everything if you love to learn and
want to be taught by people who know
their craft onedrim is a great service
that will expand your knowledge and
present a wide variety of interesting
topics i was pleasantly surprised to
learn something new from one of their
chemistry lectures apparently chemical
warfare as we know it goes as far back
as the 6th century bc in sparta where
spartans launch flaming projectiles made
of pitch and sulfur which when inhaled
would produce sulfuric acid in the lungs
of their enemies if you've ever wondered
about anything one dream will be your
new favorite place and they're giving
viewers a great offer of a free trial
show your support from my channel by
subscribing to one dream now click on
the link in the description below to
start your free trial today
cyanide is a very simple molecule it's a
carbon atom bound to a nitrogen atom via
a triple bond in nature it exists as a
salt by binding to alkaline metals like
sodium and potassium or attached to
sugar molecules called glycosides in the
pits and seeds of apples cherries and
peaches cyanide poisoning occurs through
two routes ingestion of either the salt
or sugar form or inhalation of gaseous
cyanide gaseous cyanide known as
hydrogen cyanide is created by either
exposing a cyanide salt to acid or
burning plastics made of acrylonitrile
both of which add a hydrogen atom onto
the cyanide group making gaseous
hydrogen cyanide inhalation is far more
dangerous than ingestion as cyanide gets
into the bloodstream much faster
due to its fast-acting lethality and
general ease of administration cyanide
has been used not just on an individual
level but on a large scale as well
historically for executions in world war
ii concentration camps mass suicides
such as the jonestown massacre and
public poisonings like the 1982 tylenol
cyanide poisonings
what makes cyanide so effective is that
it prevents cells from producing atp by
blocking the workings of the electron
transport chain from biology you may
recall your cells have an organelle
called the mitochondria which is
responsible for creating energy for the
cell by synthesizing the molecule atp
inside the mitochondria is an inner
membrane that contains proteins that
together make up the electron transport
chain the way it works is electrons pass
through the proteins and in doing so
cause reactions allowing proteins to
produce atp
cyanide binds to one of the enzymes in
the transport chain called cytochrome c
oxidase or the cox enzyme thereby
preventing electrons from flowing
through the chain of proteins and
halting the production of atp with the
electron transport chain out of
commission cells cannot make atp in
large quantities and must switch to a
secondary metabolism called anaerobic
metabolism but anaerobic metabolism is
not ideal firstly it only makes about
six percent of the atp that the electron
transport chain makes secondly it
produces lactic acid as a byproduct
which lowers blood ph anaerobic
metabolism is only for short-term
production of energy like sprinting or
lifting heavy weights not to sustain you
for a long period of time with having
insufficient atp production cells are
not getting the energy resources they
need and begin to malfunction very
quickly nerve cells start to have
sporadic signaling and muscle tissue has
insufficient and weak contractions this
causes the body to undergo spasms loss
of balance increased heart rate and
elevated breathing once atp supplies are
exhausted cells shut down but not all
cells in the body die at once this
causes asymmetric muscle contractions
making spasms progress to tremors the
victim falls into a coma and breathing
slows down to lethal levels the cause of
death is either asphyxiation or cardiac
arrest due to shutdown of muscle tissue
one great example of cyanide poisoning
in media is the death of joffrey
lannister in game of thrones joffrey is
poisoned with a substance called the
strangler which has very similar effects
to someone poisoned with cyanide he
initially has labored breathing muscle
spasms and disorientation which rapidly
progresses he eventually dies from
either cardiac arrest or asphyxiation
how is it that a small pill can have
such a lethal effect on the body to
understand we have to look at a unit of
measurement in chemistry called the mole
not a mole but mole one mole of a
substance is the measurement of the
number of units of that substance
whether it be an atom or a molecule
numerically one mole is equal to 6.02
times 10 to the power 23 units or 602
sextillion units of a substance for
example if you had one mole of chevy
corvettes you would have 602 sextillion
chevy corvettes and one sextillion is a
huge number for comparison here's one
trillion and here's one sextillion now
on a chemistry front this is one mole of
pure iron which means in this pile of
iron shavings there are 602 sextillion
iron atoms the lethal dose of cyanide
for a 175 pound male is 240 milligrams
240 milligrams of cyanide converts to
0.009 moles or 5.4 sextillion molecules
of cyanide while it's not one mole of
cyanide it's still an enormous amount of
cyanide molecules compared to the number
of cells in your body the human body is
estimated to be composed of 30 trillion
cells 30 trillion sounds like a lot
until you realize 30 trillion goes into
5.4 sextillion 180 million times getting
down to brass tacks when you take a
lethal dose of cyanide this means
there's about 180 million cyanide
molecules for every one cell in your
body factor in your blood carrying and
distributing those 5.4 sextillion
cyanide molecules throughout your body
and it's very easy to realize how this
small pill can be so lethal this is why
dose is so important
science youtuber cody reader made a
video several years ago where he
ingested a non-lethal dose of cyanide
again dose matters he dissolved 15
milligrams of sodium cyanide in water
and took a small drink he estimated the
dose was less than five milligrams
however even at a low dose he noted he
felt vague muscle spasms and elevated
breathing i'm starting to feel a little
bit of the effects of the cyanide you
see i got a little bit of a tremor here
my breathing is just slightly more rapid
but other than that if i didn't know
that i drank cyanide i probably wouldn't
even know i was poisoned
so what if you take a moderate dose of
cyanide where death is not immediate is
there still hopes for survival yes the
antidote for cyanide is amylnitrite
which essentially turns hemoglobin in
red blood cells into cyanide magnets
amyl nitrite is injected into the
bloodstream and oxidizes hemoglobin into
matte hemoglobin changing the charge of
the iron atom from positive 2 to
positive 3 which strongly attracts
cyanide ions this removes cyanide from
the cox enzyme freeing up the electron
transport chain allowing atp to be
produced of course you need red blood
cells to carry oxygen as well and that
hemoglobin cannot carry oxygen so the
concentration of amino nitrite being
injected cannot convert more than 30
percent of red blood cell hemoglobin in
summary cyanide can be ingested or
inhaled once in the body it binds to the
cox enzyme preventing the electron
transport chain from making atp this
causes a nervous and muscular system to
shut down resulting in asphyxiation and
or cardiac arrest the cure for cyanide
poisoning is amy nitrite which converts
the hemoglobin in red blood cells into
competitive substrates freeing up the
electron transport chain